u.s politics has seen its dark
underbelly laid bare in this election
but in rally north carolina dawn broke
the cycle
as the democratic process broke records
this is news from north carolina public
radio wunc
early in-person voting got underway this
morning across the united states
voter turnout is turning into a historic
time
good morning everyone now
eight o'clock shop and the polls are
open they cheered at doors open on day
one of voting and rally
across america 15 million had already
cast an early ballot before them voting
is important
and believe me for the nightmare that
we've
suffered in this country for the last
four years it's very important for me to
be here
i wanted to show my kids what it means
to me
how important the voter is there's a lot
going on
that i'm not happy with and
i hope my vote counts to straighten that
out and fix it
well you're not happy with i'm not happy
with joe biden
early analysis of the data shows that of
those casting their ballot early
a disproportionate number are black
voters and women
demographics that don't favor donald
trump
the vote process has been repeatedly
questioned by president trump
it's kept them busy here in a place they
call the boiler room
hey angie uh this is shelby hi kimberly
it's allison will be assigned to the
vote
hey charlie this is this is guidance for
voters
an advice hotline getting hotter they
say
because of remarks in the white house i
think one of the things that we are
concerned about
is some of the really intense rhetoric
around voter alleged voter fraud
are you know encouraging people to uh
you know to intervene
uh in you know in the act of voting
right election officials have a hard
enough job
you're asking for a lot man north
carolina's voters won't be hosting a
scheduled midweek visit
by democrat vice presidential candidate
kamala harris
after two people involved with her
campaign tested positive for covind
it's a h to affect her voting drive but
not these voters
their minds and millions more are
already made up
and their votes already cast james
matthews sky news
in rally north carolina